let me ask you about
um Gary tonan
so he
is one of the
at least in my opinion the greatest
submission Grapplers of all time there's
a lot of components to that but he lost
in his first match not only did Gary
lose he lost to the Bottom seed of his
Division and that in itself sees
something pretty remarkable about what's
happening in ADCC how
there's a sense in which the days of
the invited athletes being far superior
to the trials winners are over it was a
clear signal that anyone who makes it to
ADCC can beat the best people
um Sam McNally is a very talented uh
submission Grappler from Ireland he
specializes mostly in arm bars but he
has a good positional game as well as a
very modern look to his uh to his Jiu
Jitsu and uh he did a fantastic job
against garitonin
I think technically uh Gary perhaps got
a little far away from
uh
his true nature and grappling which is
Relentless submission attack and perhaps
uh I should be
given blame for this because they put
such a heavy emphasis on the in the
training camp overall on positional
pressure that I feel that worked very
well for all of the athletes except Gary
tonnen and um interesting so his his
Nate you have to acknowledge the nature
of the athletes and I think I was
coaching so hard to the to the new
people in the room on positional
pressure that I neglected Gary's uh uh
innate ability to it the fact that he
does best when he um attacks exclusively
by submission so I think if if anyone
should get blamed for the failure here
it should be me uh there's another
comment as uh maybe I'm over
um
overvaluing that sort of just the
physical aspect of this but it seemed
like Gary was look skinny is the weight
cut yeah he um this is the first time I
ever went down to the uh 66 kilos so
um you know it wasn't critical these
other guys who were bigger than him who
made the weight
um but the weight cut if you can just
comment on is that does that ever play a
part in the athletes the the physical
and the mental aspect of the weight cut
it is it is a thing it can wrestling
That Could Break Even some of the
toughest Minds yeah but no it wasn't a
white cat it would break someone like
Garrett's owner and it was it's more
physical you you train lighter and
weaker you tend to get injured more in
Camp because you're lighter
um we have a team now after the breakout
that's mostly comprised of people over
215 pounds so um uh there's very few
small people left in the gym most of the
smaller athletes went uh to B team so
um uh Gary's been struggling a little
bit with with training partners and
um uh but here I think the chief problem
was that uh Gary focused perhaps a
little too much on the positional
tactical game and got away from his his
true gift which is uh uh Relentless
hunting for submissions and as I said I
think the person to blame for that is me
because I put I had to put so much
emphasis on the positional game for the
for the developing athletes that I
didn't pay enough attention to Gary's
unique attributes so this I mentioned I
posted some stuff on Reddit so there's a
relevant question here uh somebody on
Reddit asked Gordon has said and perhaps
you have said as well that there are two
types of Jiu Jitsu practitioners ones
who move themselves around like Marcel
Garcia and ones that control the motion
of their opponents like Gordon what are
the strengths and weaknesses of each
approach and how do those different
approaches apply depending on which
weight class you're in that's a great
set of questions yes um uh I'm the
person who promulgates this idea that
there's two broad ways you can go on
Jiu-Jitsu you can either
focus on
promoting your own movement to create
opportunity or by restricting the other
person's movement
if you're a slower
less athletic opponent
then you should definitely focus on the
idea of restricting the other fellows
movement that's how slow unathletic
people went in Jiu Jitsu if you're quick
with the ability to change direction
stand up quickly go down quickly
and move like a leopard then you're
almost always better off generating
movement
in order to create opportunity so one is
based more on movement as the the source
of opportunity one is based more upon
pressure as the source of opportunity so
you'll get someone like Gary Turnin or
the ruatolo brothers their game is based
around the idea of promoting their own
movement to create opportunity whereas
someone like Gordon Ryan or hodra Gracie
is about restricting movement and using
that pressure
to create reactive opportunity those are
the two paths you can take in Jiu Jitsu
because our team now has become mostly
associated with people over 200 pounds
and because most of them will begin as I
took the more high percentage approach
of okay let's uh let's focus primarily
on controlling the other fellows
movement and um uh but Gary is a unique
individual and I feel like I let him
down by not uh Giving Him special
attention in regards to to what he does
the fact that you've mentioned is now
like four times in the in the span of a
few minutes just I love that that that
all of the stuff will be so heavy on you
um and he is a truly special person it
is truly interesting to see what is the
nature of a particular athlete that if
you highlight makes them shine let's go
to the part where Gary actually loses
the match okay so the match is pretty
innocuous at this point the guy does a
good job of turning into the arm
and um
Gary gets caught reaching from the knees
okay that's always a mistake and uh the
guy does I think he does a great job
capitalizing on it now there's limited
time left on the clock this guy realizes
oh this is my opportunity he's got good
flexibility and he gets the Hawks if we
just freeze it right there
so there's a minute and a half left and
typically an 80cc if you get the bag you
score three points so uh this is a huge
score
um for Gary to win here it's got to be
by submission okay so Gary's made one
mistake now
um this talented young fellow from
Ireland does a great job not only of
getting the bag but he really attacks
well from the back and let's look at the
depth of Gary toner's defensive Acumen
here and we should say leading up to
this his defense is incredible yeah
our nickname for Gary is the slippery
salmon because he's like trying to hold
a goddamn salmon on the river bank
trying to hold on to this kid so he gets
into a position which looks absolutely
hopeless here it gets worse this is
already bad but
um
um it's one of the most fun things about
to watch while Gary is the skill and the
escapes it's incredible it's it's
beautiful to watch so the guy has an
excellent opportunity to transition off
him into a rare triangle which is one of
the hardest things in the world to get
out of and from here if this was anyone
by Gary tone and I think it would have
been curtains but you see Gary just
extends keeps his arm at the just the
right angle to pop out and gets out so
now Gary's like oh crap I'm gonna lose
to this [ __ ] guy so he's got a minute
left to do something so he goes back
into his submission mode he goes back to
who Gary tonan is and immediately goes
into leg lock action
now
the the young man from Ireland realizes
hey I'm going to win this match against
the number one seed so Gary goes into
the legs
gets to one of his favorite techniques
the the heel hook
now Gary has a brutal heel Hawk his egg
and gets real pressure on the kid's leg
oh oh that's hard to watch yeah but to
his credit the kid is smart he's like
you know what let me uh he's just let me
take some is there a weakness to that
like well he turned his hips yeah it's
unclear from the video whether
Gary's uh um slipped up with his
considerable braking pressures oh it
slipped yeah yeah it's unclear even
before but sometimes the heel can slip
because it's because something's popped
so it's unclear what happened there
there seems to be a reaction from the
part of the opponent like it definitely
did some damage so Gary goes back for a
second one oh no and again you get that
same kind of pressure oh no all right
but I I like I like the Irish kids
reaction though he's just like you know
what let me eat this because I'm gonna
win this match and I'm gonna be a legend
for beating Gary Tony so I admired his
internal fortitude and um but now Gary
knows he's lost it so it there's a
sensor in which you you see how
close it gets in these situations how
little there is between winner and loser
and sometimes you just get these
heartbreaking
situations where someone who ordinarily
you would probably do very well against
and you make one mistake and it's an
it's an unrewarding uncompromising sport
one mistake can be fatal